[Music]
he famously promised
you'll never walk alone and over the
last year
this nation clung to those words
[Music]
jerry marsden with his unmistakable
smile
was the heart and soul of the band jerry
and the pacemakers
who made the song famous
[Music]
[Applause]
a hit in the 1960s mersey beat scene
they completed sellout tours around the
world
and were the first ever band to reach
number one in the uk
charts with their first three singles
the tributes were led by liverpool
football club
which adopted you'll never walk alone as
its anthem
jerry's words will live on forever with
us
the club's former chief executive
tweeted this video
of what he described as one of the most
treasured members of the lfc family
the news of jerry marsden's death was
confirmed by his agent and surviving
band members
who wrote losing such a legend is never
easy
we were all blessed to work with jerry
for many years
[Music]
jerry's heart was always in his hometown
in liverpool
where he remains a local icon jenny's
legacy will be
of course as one of the leaders of the
mersey beat era
and uh jenny was a a tough
man he was a tough lad and his youth and
he's a tough man
but he was also a very caring and loving
man it is the words of you'll never walk
alone you know
there is a golden sky isn't it and um
for many people that sky is a little bit
darker
jerry marsden died on sunday morning at
the age of 78
but not before he saw his famous song
reach number one once more
this time bringing the nation together
during a pandemic
when the words seemed more like a prayer
sadia chowdhury sky news